from downtown and he ties the game with  13 seconds remaining  come on now you've got plenty of time  here whether you isolate or what  but make sure you have spacing there it  is right there  marcus smart on the drive trying to draw  a contact  on the follow it's gone pritchard banks  at home  with two tenths of a second remaining  the rookie with the big play and the  celtics lead by two  [Music]  you love to see it what an ending  because we all know with two tenths of a  second left  we all know that you can't catch and  shoot  you have to make a tap so consequently  this is just a great play right here  miss  go right back up again in traffic with